dear Miss fuller and the other  assistants of the little tea shop just a  few lines to let you know how we're all  keeping the six have been in the  trenches twice a good few of them had to  go to hospital through the cold and  exposure they're hardly fit for this  line of work we were in the trenches on  Christmas Day we spent the midea day  than we expected  there was a truce to bury our dead we  had a short service over the graves  conducted by our minister and the German  one he read the 23rd psalm and had a  short prayer I don't think I will ever  forget the Christmas Day I spent in the  trenches after the service we were  speaking to the Germans and getting  souvenirs from them and see shaking  hands with the enemy I suppose you'll  hardly believe this but it's the truth  I often think about a little Keisha and  wonder how you're getting on private be  called a sex Gordon Highlanders regiment  he company  [Music]